why is this a big we're comparing
different products for different genders
usually it's like the exact same
substances and they just put like a more
masculine packaging on it
this is cocoa butter formula are you
kidding me with this this is the same
thing for womens it's been white and for
a men it's been gray silver industrial
fast absorbing fights dry skin so I
guess men always fight cuz fights is
strong masculine that's dumb whereas the
the women's product is like sues and
calms and like toning Healing softens
like women needs saw oh I'm gonna look
at the active ingredients I swear to God
if this is not the exact same thing
water water
Coco Coco it is the same thing
sexy intrigue mmm sexy intrigue for I'm
already like offended by this because
this one has like a you know hourglass
silhouette oh and then the male one is
just straight and it's like oh is this
supposed to be the ideal female body
women don't workout or play sports just
looks like it's good for sedentary
movement throughout your day so it's
just to make sure that's for men you
have a person rock climbing here it's
called adventure all men must like
sports some guys using us will just be
sitting at a computer all day and not
rock climbing faasil me mango like come
on and this one's called swagger I don't
think it's a huge deal with a girl use
this one or if a guy use that one
[Music]
um ah this is so dumb
are you kidding it's for taking care of
your baby those you're just like all the
men are I'm doing it the women are the
one clean links women use these for
first aid yeah it's the mom household
chores
cuz you assume women are out here
cleaning the house okay this is just
rude
you think that's tailored to women look
how stereotypical ridiculous BS guy
stuff this yeah it even looks like a
[ __ ] toolbox okay just q-tips man
perfect for getting into small spaces to
care for a man's possessions let me tell
you what a man is doing with this q-tip
it's touching his electronics model
building what are you gonna build with a
q-tip motorcycle cleaning what person is
going to take a q-tip out to the car
it's clickless household fixtures the
only thing that dudes expected to clean
up is his pubes out of the shower drain
mine screams handyman around the house
and mine is like are you kidding I'm so
shook right now like what kook
this makes me think like ah damn it I
got to do some work but I see this and
it's like oh this is gonna make me look
fly and beautiful so yeah I'm gonna go
with the chick cute it's if at the end
of the day we're all trying to
accomplish the same thing whether it's
getting clean shaving staying fresh why
does it have to be specifically tailored
towards your gender why treasures just
have like a unisex kind of product
because it doesn't even make any
difference just make it like extra
protection and like regular okay I'm
gonna get the extra male or female yeah
or whatever you identify as we're pitch
what's that stereotype that women have
to be curvy and smell very flowery and
they're dainty this is like women are
delicate if you're so delicate sensitive
skin and I'm like I'm sensitive I have
feelings I want to go skydiving I want
to be adventurous I want to do running
climb your mouth I love black hide your
motorcycle we worked back at the a droid
in 1950s now I think they're like so
absurd and we're gonna look at these and
be like what were these people thinking
this is the woman on the cover is like
like I don't know what what you're
wiping away in this part of your face
the tears from oppression through
gendered community products perhaps